نبدا اسبوعنا وصباحنا اليوم بحديث ونقاش
صحي عالميا هام يمس اسلوب حياتنا اليوميه
فرغم كل الدراسات الطبيه والنصائح
والحملات التوعويه حول التغذيه صدرت تقرير
صادم عن صحتنا في المستقبل القريب التقرير
صادر عن الاتحاد العالمي للسمنه كشف ان
اكثر من نصف سكان العالم سيعانون من زياده
الوزن او السمنه بحلول عام 2035 جاء في
التقرير ان معدلات السمنه اخذ في الارتفاع
بسرعه خصوصا بين الاطفال وفي الدول منخفضه
الدخل البيانات هو الارقام وصفت ووصفت
بالتحذير الواضح وناشد معده تقرير
الحكومات وصانعي السياسات بالتحرك العاجل
لمنع تدهور الوضع مزيد حول ارقام السمنه
مع علاء سرحان
توقع الاتحاد العالمي للسمنه ان واحدا
وخمسين في المئه من سكان العالم اي ما
يتجاوز اربعه مليارات نسمه سيعانون من
السمنه او زياده الوزن خلال الاثني عشر
عاما المقبله افاد تقرير المنظمه بان
السمنه في الاطفال قد تتجاوز ضعفي مستويات
2020 سيكون الاولاد اكثر سمنه لتصل الى
ملايين فتى ومائه 150 مليون فتاه بحلول
عام 2035 اما بالنسبه لتكلفه علاجات
الامراض الناتجه عن ذلك ستتجاوز اربعه
تريليونات دولار سنويا بحلول 2035 اي ما
يعادل 3% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
العالمي وفي عام 2020 تم تصنيف مليارين
و600 مليون شخص اي
38% من سكان العالم ضمن فئتين زياده الوزن
والسمنه وفقا لارشادات منظمه الصحه
العالميه اذا زاد مؤشر كتله الجسم على 25
فانه يعني زياده الوزن واذا زاد على 30
يعني سنه
في الاستوديو تنظيم الينا طبيبه الاطفال
الدكتوره ريتا سابا ريتا يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك يعني الدراسه صادمه فعلا اكثر من نصف
سكان العالم نتحدث عن اكثر من اربعه
مليارات نسمه سيعانون من السمنه خلال عقد
فقط يعني ما مدى دقه هذه الدراسه حتى كمان
الدراسات برهنت انه خلال السنوات اللي
قطعت تقريبا
الارقام عند السمنه والوزن الزائد عند
الاطفال تضاعفت عن الاطفال وتقريبا دافت
اربع مرات عند المراهقين وهذا الشيء بقسم
مش بس على صحه الاطفال كمان بتاثر على
مستقبلهم مشان هيك لازم ناخذ هذا الموضوع
بشكل كثير جدي ونجرب نشتغل على الوقايه
وعلى العلاج طيب دكتور ريتا هل يعني في
عندنا جين هو خصوصي للسمنه يعني في موضوع
وراثي ولازم احنا بنستسلم لاله ما بنقدر
نعمل اي لا اكيد في في عنا عده عوامل
بتاثر على السمنه عند الاطفال اهميتها في
عنا الموضوع الوراثي وموضوع الجيني بس
كمان في عنا اسباب ثانيه اس الهرمونيه او
مرات بتكون خلل بالغدد عند الاطفال وكمان
عوامل خارجيه مثل الاكل غير الصحي الطفل
ما بيمارس الرياضه بشكل مستمر الاطفال
بتقعد وقت طويل على الالعاب الالكترونيه
على التلفاز وعلى كل شيء تابلت وحتى النوم
النوم غالي المنتظم باثر على السمنه عند
الاطفال وكمان الدراسات برهنت ان الاطفال
يلي بتنام بوقت متاخر عرضه لانه تصير
عندها سمنه وزيت بالوزن بالنسبه للاطفال
بتنام بوقت مبكر طيب بالنسبه للجميع يا
ريت ليس فقط الاطفال السمنه تمس الجميع ما
هي قلت انه لازم التركيز على الوقايه
والعلاج ما سبل الوقايه والعلاج ما
النصائح كدكتوره هلا الوقايه بتبلش فينا
نحنا كاطباء وكاهل كمان لانه نحن دائما
الاهل هم قدوه للاطفال منبلش نحنا نكون
قدوه للاطفال كمان سعر بالوقايه يعني لازم
نجرب قد ما فينا ندخل الاكل الصحي على
البيت ما نطلب كثير الوجبات السريعه على
البيت نشيل السكريات والحلويات
ونجرب قد ما فينا ما نعط كتير المشروبات
اللي فيها سكر مثل العصائر يعني احنا
بنفكر عم نعطي عصير للطفل يعني
بالذات الوقت نحن عم نعطيه كتير سعرات
حراريه وسكر بزياده للاطفال ولازم كمان
مناعه الحلويات مثل كانه جائزه للطفله اذا
بتعمل هيك بعطيك انا السكر او لانه نحن
بنكون عم نساعد الاطفال يصير في عنا
بعلاقه مش مضبوطه مع الحلو فبتبلش معنا
نحن بنحفز كمان الاطفال يعملوا رياضيات
الرياضه ويعملوا العاب بالهواء الطالق بره
بنشيل الاطفال عن الايباد قد مافينا عن
التابلت يعني نجرب قد ما فينا نحدد ساعتين
بس ماكسيموم نقعد الطفل على على جهازات
الالكترونيه هذا فيما يتعلق بالاطفال لما
بنحكي على الكبار بشكل عام بس احنا كمان
يعني صار في وعي اكثر للناس عم نلاحظ
بيعملوا صيام متقطع وبيعملوا مثلا كيتو
وحتى الاسواق صار في منها انواع اكل مثلا
نختلفه عن ما كانت عن 10 سنين طب يعني كيف
بده يبرر انه راح يصير في سمنه كمان مره
بعد 10 سنين لانه نحن ما بشكل المضبوط
دايما لازم يكون في متابعه من اخصائيه
التغذيه وحتى من طبيب اطفال وبطبيب الاهل
مش بس نحن نفوت فيهم هذول
هيك لازم نكون نحن في عنا حدا عم بيوجهنا
على هالطريقه الصح شكرا جزيلا طبيبه
الاطفال دكتوره ريتا سابا نورتينا دكتور
شكرا لالكم